non on va parler donc culture encore et
on va parler de la Nuit des Musées
Aurélia avec votre première invité oui
tout à fait donc nous recevons Lucie
Sauvageau vous êtes responsable de
l'action culturelle pour le musée de la
ville de Saint-Quentin et à l'occasion
donc de la Nuit des musées qui se
tiendra samedi vous proposer des
animations et on en reparlera peut-être
dans quelques instants
on revient tout de suite à la Nuit des
Musées donc en effet les visiteurs vont
pouvoir découvrir le musée de nuit mais
pas seulement mais pas seulement il y a
cette année avec à côté du musée sur le
pulsion Barbie plus exactement juste à
l'extérieur immédiatement extérieur un
atelier de création collective animée
par l'artiste un artiste lui-même un des
artistes qui a une de ses œuvres dans
l'exposition plastique donc en fait les
visiteurs vont pouvoir participer à
cette oeuvre absolument il ne sait même
le principe de la création collective
plusieurs types de deux manières c'est à
dire on leur demande de contribuer à la
création en apportant des objets en
plastique alors des objets rebus de
préférence parce que c'est le principe
du travail de cet artiste et ensuite de
participer au montage de l'oeuvre
collectivement ensemble avec l'artiste
des montages de luminaires en
l'occurrence oui alors l'idée aussi
c'est de travailler sur la matière
plastique absolument c'est tout à fait
en lien avec l'exposition donc plastique
plastoc cet artiste régissèrent et
surnommé ce surnomme lui-même le prince
du plastique on l'évoquera peut-être
plus tard parce qu'il travaille beaucoup
à travers de du plastique et de
matériaux recyclés en général le
plastique étant le matériau évoqué en
premier lieu quand on parle de recyclage
c'est surtout autour de ce matériel là
qu'il a travaillé et là ce sera
exclusivement à partir de plastique
effectivement qu'on va travailler voilà
puisqu'en même temps en parallèle donc
de cette nuit des musées vous présenter
une exposition qui est ouverte là déjà
depuis le 24 avril autour du plastique
donc l'idée sous-jacente à nouveau je
crois dans cette dans cet événement là
de samedi c'est aussi de de montrer le
lien qui peut y avoir entre le plastique
et le design absolument de montrer ce
lien c'est tout à fait ce que fait
régisseur il travaille énormément il
fait des mobiliers des éléments de
mobilier des reconstitutions de
l'Intérieur également c'était aussi ça
le jeu avec l'intérieur et l'extérieur
du musée et le but du jeu c'était
effectivement de montrer ce lien entre
le plastique et le design qui est abordé
tout au long de cette exposition dans le
musée de la ville et de montrer cette
réflexion aussi sur la valeur du du
plastique et du design en plastique qui
peut être à la fois une oeuvre d'art
comme le démontrera régisseur et tous
les participants à cette soirée et qui
peut aussi être considéré comme du
plastoc comme des rebuts comme un
matériau non notation un peu péjorative
en effet alors cet artiste régisseur
comment vous l'avez choisi pourquoi lui
alors pourquoi lui on avait il y a
plusieurs artistes qui travaillent à
partir du plastique pour quoi lui pour
différentes raisons d'une part ce qu'on
a travaillé pour cette exposition avec
le musée du peigne et de la place surgi
à Oyonnax qui avait déjà travaillé avec
régisseur sur un projet important de
ville en plastique et c'est par leur
intermédiaire au départ qu'on a connu
régisseur et puis l'autre raison c'est
que cet artiste
tiens vraiment il lui tient à cœur
l'idée de faire participer les gens que
l'art soit accessible à tous qu'il soit
dans la rue sur les places publiques et
c'est aussi ça qui est important pour
nous muser c'est aussi ce qu'on fait
quotidien c'est ce que fait
l'agglomération en général et voilà
c'est les valeurs qu'on peut transmettre
alors régisseur pas pu malheureusement
être sur le plateau ce soir malgré tout
nous avons recueilli quelques mots il
nous parle de son travail et de la façon
dont il met en oeuvre son art on va
l'écouter
un maximum de publics
la manière des aborder le fait de
travailler avec des objets très courants
et des matériaux pauvres les oeuvres que
je crée sont assez universel ça passe la
barrière de culture des conditions
sociales de l'âge les enfants ça leur
plaît beaucoup
les personnes plus âgées ça leur parle
aussi effectivement moi je travaille
quasi uniquement à partir de déchets
bordures de de ce qui est jeté des
considérés il y a comment quelque chose
de pédagogique de changer le regard sur
notre environnement sur ce que ce qui
est valorisé ou pas enfin il y a un
discours social écologique citoyen
là-dessus
alors voilà donc régisseur on a vu là
une partie de son travail en effet en
extérieur
mais qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît particulièrement là dans ce qu'il
fait vraiment à la fois la simplicité de
l'homme vous avez pu le voir la danse
reportage c'est quelqu'un qui est très
très accessible et qui a malgré
l'apparente simplicité de ses œuvres qui
est l'humour important qu'il y a dansé
dans ses réalisations il y a une
profonde réflexion en fait sur la valeur
des choses sur la vanité de la vie sur
sur le le la société de consommation en
général sur l'utilisation des matières
naturelles non naturelles et c'est une
profonde réflexion qui fait même écho à
des sémiologues Roland Bart en
particulier enfin il y a une profondeur
vraiment derrière ce discours qui nous
intéresse et vous pensez que ce message
va
réussir à se transmettre là aux
visiteurs que vous allez recevoir samedi
oui absolument d'une part parce que avec
ce lien avec l'exposition ça amène
forcément à une réflexion d'autre part
parce que le but c'est pas forcément non
plus qui passe soirée à réfléchir mais
qui s'amusent et qu'ils en profitent
notamment à l'écran l'idée c'est
d'arriver à créer un luminaire un
luminaire même plusieurs luminaires
celui-là est un qui a été indilluminaire
créé par par Régis serre lui-même l'idée
c'est effectivement de produire c'est
luminaires un peu un peu géant et de
créer une œuvre qui soit vraiment
intéressante et qu'on exposera ensuite
nous au musée on exposera ses luminaires
ou au moins une partie d'entre eux le
but c'est vraiment que les gens fassent
une oeuvre une vraie oeuvre qui sera
exposée dans un musée c'est une oeuvre
dans une oeuvre une oeuvre dans une
heure alors justement l'exposition
puisqu'on en parlait est ouvert depuis
le 24 avril ce que vous pouvez déjà nous
donner quelques retours alors oui c'est
une exposition qui plaît beaucoup aux
gens qui qui
desquels on a eu des retours et surtout
qui amène beaucoup de réactions des gens
qui sont confrontés à des objets qui
leur sont familiers et qui en fait on
remarque qu'ils sont très attachés la
plupart du temps un rapport très
affectif à ses objets c'est normal la
plupart de ces objets viennent des
habitants de Saint-Quentin eux-mêmes qui
nous les ont donnés et on il y a une
voilà une grande affection liée à ces
objets c'est aussi là-dessus porte le
travail de régisseur d'ailleurs qui lui
est un grand récupérateur comme les le
musée comme le sont les musées et qui
garde ses objets parce qu'il y a attaché
et c'est ce que font les habitants aussi
en nous donnant des objets ou dans le
musée justement peut-être aussi ceux qui
suscite le plus de réactions
d'attachement alors c'est surtout les
objets des années 60 qui ont été
vraiment la période de postularisation
pardon la nostalgie d'objets qui ont eu
nos parents nos grands-parents ou que
les gens de qui sont installés sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin à sa
création ont eu la balance Terraillon
qui a un grand classique bon les poupées
Barbie qu'on a tous eu il y a aussi les
téléphones à cadran orange je pense que
vous voyez tous de quoi on parle voilà
ces objets qu'on a tous vu tous eu qui
sont très familiers et alors notamment
dans le cadre de cette exposition
vous avez mis en place un concours
concours d'objet kitsch donc là c'est
l'occasion de on relance l'appel pour
que chacun envoie une petite photo de
justement l'objet qu'il affectionne et
puis peut-être c'est un grand gagnant et
l'objectif c'est tout à fait ça qui nous
intéresse dans cet objectif c'est que
c'est une question de jugement de valeur
et que c'est un objet en général qu'on
ne jette pas parce qu'on y est attaché
mais que foncièrement on trouve lait en
général c'est pour ça qu'on le définit
du alors moi j'ai un cheval en plastique
comme ça
et qui que j'ai mis d'ailleurs dans
l'exposition dans l'objectif dans le
concours d'objectif bon moi je ne peux
pas gagner mais je méritais d'être
montré ce cheval en plastique et
effectivement l'idée c'est qu'on nous
envoie des photos d'objet kitsch soit on
peut les déposer au musée mais on peut
aussi les les poster directement sur
Facebook pour participer au concours on
peut simplement voter sur Facebook si on
ne souhaite pas dévoiler ses secrets
d'objectif c'est possible voilà donc on
peut aussi juste voter et participer de
cette manière là alors on rappelle donc
pour la nuit des musées qui a lieu donc
samedi vous devrez à 18h à 18 jusqu'à
23h et donc l'idée c'est de venir avec
un objet avec un objet en plastique quel
que ça peut être par exemple ça peut
être un seau de plage que les enfants
laissaient dans un coin ça peut être
d'accord là c'est un objet qu'on doit
recycler oui à recycler tout objet qui
désormais est inutilisé et que qui
embarrasse presque qui embarrasse et
ou auquel on a attaché et qu'on voudrait
voir réutiliser dans une œuvre ça c'est
vraiment au choix des gens ça peut être
des biberons ça peut être
en plastique
ben écoutez Lucie merci beaucoup donc
voilà on lance l'appel pour samedi pour
le la visite du musée de la ville en
nocturne et puis on vous souhaite
beaucoup de beaucoup de public merci
on va vous livrer à présent une petite
sélection d'autres dates pour fêter
cette nuit des musées dans le reste du
département puisque d'autres d'autres
événements peuvent avoir lieu alors une
petite sélection de trois dates on va
commencer par le musée de Port-Royal
Deschamps donc à Magny-les-Hameaux qui
propose un concert de musique de la
Renaissance à nos jours et c'est
présenté par l'ensemble couleur cuivre
donc samedi évidemment à 20h suivi si
vous le souhaitez à Rambouillet au musée
le rambolitain la possibilité d'une
balade nocturne en train vapeur
également la découverte d'animation de
jouets mécaniques de la fin du 19e
siècle donc de 20h à 1h du matin à
Rambouillet et vous avez également la
possibilité de visiter les grands
appartements et la galerie des glaces au
château de Versailles de 20 heures
à minuit pour cette petite sélection
bien sûr des événements il y en a
beaucoup ils sont nombreux on voulait se
faire votre choix bien évidemment
c'était la sélection d'Aurélien vous
assumez ses choix que vous nous avez
livré